et isabelle le callennec mais merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
santé
il y a dix ans 90% des français avaient
une opinion favorable des vaccins
aujourd'hui 41% estiment que les vaccins
ne sont pas sûres quand l' oms affirme
pourtant que la vaccination est vite
chaque année deux à trois millions de
décès dans le monde dans notre pays
seuls trois maladies sont pas
vaccination obligatoire la diphtérie le
tétanos et la polio mais il est quasi
impossible de se procurer des vaccins
contre ces seules maladies sont
commercialiser des vaccins qui en
combine plusieurs notamment contre la
coqueluche ou l'hépatite b vaccin eux
n'est obligatoire
un kit spécifique existe bien mais il
est réservé aux enfants qui présentent
des contre indications à la suite d'une
pétition qui a rassemblé plus d'un
million de signatures et à la saisine
par plus de 2000 parents n'ayant pas
réussi à obtenir le vaccin en question
le conseil d'état a rendu un avis le 8
février je le cite la loi qui n'impose
que trois obligation de vaccination
implique de s'y conformer
en usant de vaccins qui ne contiennent
que ces trois vaccine action il vous
enjoint donc madame la ministre à
prendre des mesures pour rendre
disponibles dans les six mois
les vaccin dtp trois options s'offrent
apparemment à vous demander aux
laboratoires de respecter l'obligation
d'organiser un plan de gestion des
stocks ouvrir la voie à la concurrence
en faisant appel à une licence d'office
permettre à lagence santé publique
d'acheter d'importer et de distribuer
les médicaments dans la
commercialisation et la production sont
jugées insuffisantes à ce stade madame
la ministre
quelles options a votre préférence
comment comptez vous rassurer les
français et notamment les jeunes parents
qui sont en droit d'attendre des
informations claires et fiables
merci la parole est à madame marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la députée isabelle le callennec je
partage
avec vous la volonté de rappeler aux
français l'importance absolument majeur
de la vaccination
la vaccination est un enjeu de santé
publique avec lequel il ne faut pas
plaisanter et c'est vrai que dans notre
pays plus qu'ailleurs s'est installé une
défiance une défiance qui a des causes
multiples mais qui trouve notamment un
point de fixation
lors de la crise de la grippe h1n1 qui a
provoqué des interrogations chez
beaucoup de nos concitoyens
vous évoquez une décision du conseil
d'état qui enjoint au gouvernement de
permettre l'accès à des vaccins
comportant seulement les trois vaccins
obligatoires
alors qu'aujourd'hui le vaccin le plus
fréquent comporte six vaccination en
même temps je veux vous rappeler que
indépendamment de cette décision du
conseil d'état
j'ai lancé une concertation confiée au
professeur fisher dont les résultats ont
été remis il ya quelques semaines cette
consultation propose là de rendre
obligatoire non pas six vaccins mais
onze vaccin donc il ya aujourd'hui
plusieurs options qui sont sur la table
qui font actuellement l'objet d'
expertise juridique de la part de mes
services je recevrai à nouveau le
professeur fisher au début du mois de
mars et j'annoncerai mes orientations
j'assumerai mes responsabilités madame
la députée en proposant puisqu'il est
probable qu'un texte législatif sera
nécessaire en proposant les éléments
d'un dispositif législatif qu'il
appartiendra évidemment à la prochaine
assemblée de mettre en oeuvre mais
j'annoncerai les orientations que je
préconise madame la députée dans
quelques petites semaines